we do have one more piece of news that
we want to report about it's about our
show we never want to let Anthony go but
we have to we can't work six days a week
so we are thrilled to announce that
starting on June 22nd Jeff Glor will be
joining CBS this morning Saturday as a
co-host in addition to that role Jeff
will also serve as a CBS News special
correspondent he'll continue the great
work he's done for over 12 years at the
network telling stories across a wide
range of topics and doing important
investigative work for shows across CBS
News we couldn't be happier that he's
gonna be part of our team and he gets
the beverages on Saturday Anthony you
don't get him anything that I'm saying
Jeff's like just a great choice I'm so
excited about this and for you guys as
well but I'm most excited that he'll
give me the chance to sleep in on a
Saturday after seven years you can toast
us from your bed I will cocktail there
that's a good idea I remember his first
day here